crisis energética en cuba y con ella
continúan los apagones los cubanos
acostumbrados a este tipo de situaciones
esperan pacientes fuera de sus casas
para aplacar el calor pero son otros
tiempos y no temen en mostrar su
descontento
[Música]
noticia 1 esta situación
bastante bastante intolerancia ya
el presidente cubano miguel díaz canel
recorrió esta semana todas las centrales
termoeléctricas la mayoría con
tecnología obsoleta la unión eléctrica
de cuba ha notificado más de 300
afectaciones en las 13 centrales del
país sus trabajadores extienden a 12
horas su jornada laboral para atenuar la
situación
el mandatario cubano dijo que por el
momento no habrá mejora una inversión en
termoeléctrica es sumamente costoso para
el país y por otra parte es una
inversión que demora años osea de
inmediato no se logra montar un arte
moderno con un país amigo tiene suscrito
un acuerdo una negociación mediante la
cual se establecerían tres nuevos
bloques en el país eso es pensando en el
crecimiento que va a tener el país en el
futuro expertos temen que la situación
se escale y lleva a los cubanos otra vez
a la calle como la tormenta perfecta
o sea ya ha pasado o sea paso la
pandemia q está en una crisis económica
profunda ya hubo protestas
significativas del año pasado se ha
mantenido ese sentimiento de descontento
social ahora vuelve los apagones llega
el verano
es como todo al mismo tiempo las
sanciones contra rusia uno de los
principales aliados de la habana por su
invasión a ucrania el aumento de los
precios de los alimentos y del petróleo
agudiza la crisis en el país caribeño
impactaba principalmente por el embargo
económico estadounidense